bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono affari j
oggi domenica siamo nel weekend e quindi
happy wheels prima di cominciare ragazzi
tenevo a dirvi soltanto una cosa ho
risolto il problema il fastidiosissimo
problema che ho sempre avuto nei miei
video del microfono troppo alto la
soluzione è stata difficilissima da
trovare ma alla fine l'ho trovata è
molto complicata praticamente da così ho
fatto così
ok raga direi che possiamo iniziare epic
dump 2
non ho idea di cosa sia ovviamente anche
se avevamo già fatto l'altra volta eh
vabbè è la cosa più schifosa che abbia
mai visto
ok ok
notate come si tiene la sedia perché
perché praticamente penso che si stia
sforzando per farla tutta ma questo
livello veramente la cosa più schifosa
che abbia mai giocato e lasciamo perdere
9 9 9 9 9 9 99 impossible non mi
chiedete perché lo chiamano così andiamo
con
ed io no andiamo con il padre che è
meglio allora uk devi riuscire a
sorpassare impossibile non so ma deve
riuscirci ok vai vai look molto bravo ok
st livello alto livello infattibile raga
è assurdo ok ok ok non è esattamente
così
ok vai vai vai vedere lei no no ok senza
senza braccia
luke poverino è andato vabbè raga mi è
venuta un'idea prova a fare tipo limbo
mi abbasso qua ci vuole la musichetta
adatta cazzo impossible poco due c'è ma
tu mi stai accusando che io non riesco a
finire un livello col poco ma sanno con
chi stanno parlando questi c'è ma non ci
crederai mai steve mi hanno detto che è
impossibile finire questo livello
colposo facciamogliela vedere depp si
impossible or not of course not by
[Musica]
prima tentativo mamma mia si ma che
colpì a siamo steve ma scherziamo ad
arona devo rifarlo assolutamente raga
provo a farlo un secondo strisciando
dato che non ci riesco più a sky
se vai steve dove riportarti anche le
gambe perché sennò non vai tanto lontano
va beh non ci riesco più me ne farò una
ragione 99 per cento harpoon non ho idea
di che cosa sia
andiamo con stavolta siamo ed iva the
fly oddio m è quello di prima uguale
ok ci provai ed allora steve ci è
riuscito subito vediamo quanto sei forte
tu perfetto sei una pippa
sei una [ __ ] pippa è di guarda al
corpo tela hanno anche portato via per
superare telo effettivamente raga questo
ancora più difficile di quello di prima
non è di so che ce la può fare è di non
deluderci non deluderci che steve non
l'ha fatto si è di si è di così
allungati come mister fantastic
grandissimo ed in un happy with che si
rispetti ci vuole almeno uno smog trovo
se non siamo contenti o mio dio questo è
fantastico
ok raga proviamo prima con nonno ciak
che sta sopra una roba rossa che non
sono e che cos'è mela regge un secondo
grazie perfetto tiro
va bene non la triturato perché non è
riuscito a cadere bene fortunatamente
andiamo con la besa madonna che mira di
merda ci riprovo
by the sea in the brain a ok
vai col bambino madonna che mira che
mira a shock questo ragazzi voleva
replay non so come ho fatto a prenderlo
ma mi manca solo la bambina
vai ok ho preso il povero nonno ciak
manca ancora una spalla ce la posso fare
se riesco sempre a prenderla allunga
stefania la meester fantastico mai fatto
prima fai vedere chi sei non riesco non
riesco a prenderla spada maledizione non
riesco raga finché non li prendo tutti
il origini provo perché devo riuscirci
se no non sono contento
latifa dietro dai set chi manca allora
bambino gli offesi tutti manca soltanto
non lo shock dai dai prendilo se no
cazzo cazzo manca l'ultima spada
no non ci posso credere no non ci voglio
credere
non ci non posso essere così idiota dai
ok raga oblò this world trovo non so che
cos'è ma è un altro sport roma dovrebbe
devo riuscirci maledizione non possono
finire neanche uno smart rho mi sento
uno veramente un deficiente oddio sac
anello tutti oddio ma che cazzo ma come
c'è finita lì vabbè
ok poi mi occupi la zona maledetta
vabbè è una roba oscena mi sembra di
infilzare tacchino di della festa del
ringraziamento
vabbè riprovo non ho idea di come ci sia
finita lì ance cosa che sparo capito
però oddio non mi cadere di nuovo lì
perché almeno demolisci duke ok
voglio soltanto vedere dove va a finire
poi mio zio
oh mio dio sta succedendo di tutto come
mai penzola come mai sta penzolando ok
non voglio saperlo è rimasto soltanto
vivo uno che era giù e non riuscirò mai
a prendere lo so già
ok ok mio dio raga non riuscirò mai a
prendere l'ultimo che è rimasto lo so
già per all aperto
c'è grande di questo questo non vuol
trovo di quelli coi contro [ __ ] ok
raga un altro impossible iii all
impossible me li mangio a colazione
barca e luke dobbiamo utilizzare la
forza padre e figlio
ok non è esattamente quello che
intendeva by yoox rega questo è
veramente impossibile se non riuscirò
mai a farlo a me a parte adesso dai dai
dai
no ce la posso fare ragazza posso fare
c'è la porta mi hanno trapanato
letteralmente subito dopo ma ce l'ho
fatta
world bene ok devo provarci c'è una
spalla subito la prendo cosa devono fare
qui
ma c'è un rivale o già morto e già morto
ma ho già vinto non ho fatto niente
vabbè ci riprova dai mi stacco perfetto
la mancata se no dai
ok ti batterò brutto stronzo vieni qua
io sono tipo island andavo tagliati la
testa
ce la posso fare se quasi non ho più una
gamba ma ce la faccio lo stesso dai no o
casco fissano ucciso da solo la mia
gamba vi vendicherà cosa fai gamba mi
tradisci no gamba mi stai tradendo cosa
fai devi colpire lui ninja training camp
cosa può essere dai sarà una roba tipo
da me ovunque
ok l'apprendista e steve son guerre in
nevada
ok preferivo a coral wayne o dove cazzo
sono perfetto stonehenge e fantastico a
intruder a introd e addio maledetto
stronzo steve non lo puoi battere così
ok anche luke che tenta di fottermi
steve ma non addio le sto schifo hanno
tutti in un modo epico al primo
tentativo ok
steve è un pro c'è poco da dire mamma
mia sono riuscito anche a dividerlo a
metà 1 non ci posso credere
mio dio mi sento veramente tipo mi sento
tipo rambo in questo momento vice steve
vai sim non fatti
ok la donna si è suicidata preferito ha
visto come sono morti gli altri ha
preferito non sfidarsi perfetto vai
grandissimo steve sei un killer nato se
riesco a superarla magari la tipa mi fa
un favore
dov'è il prossimo ostacolo non ho paura
di niente io steve siamo troppo forti
stage free shuriken rain o cazzo questo
la vedo brutta by steve madonna che
schivata non ci credo non si possono
mica se finisco questo mito nofal santo
no si è laica boss contro gli shuriken
se non ci credo non ci posso credere csi
four
puoi controllare se per caso notifiche
su facebook no vabbè come al solito una
spada enorme ma non mi fa paura
no non ci credo che ho schivato
l'impossibile o nono stivato questo no
non ci credo non ci posso ho schivato di
tutto in uno schivato uno che stava
fermo dai steve non ci credo e spartito
anche un braccio vabbè lasciamo perdere
comunque steve complimenti hai dato la
prova di essere un ninja nato devo
provare a fare un altro che ancora non
l'ho fatto
ok perfetto vai e ti facciamo di vedere
chi siamo dei nube
ok riproviamoci by uk and bear ok
nicchia che pronuncia la schifo vai
avanti justin bieber ancora in hub very
good perfetto stiamo migliorando raga
perfetto good dai mancano tre palloni
ancora niente uk and bear ancora uno
ancora uno no [ __ ]
raga devono vincerlo assolutamente ci
provo si ok sarà finendo in justin
bieber ma l'ho tolta perfetto
io candle bel air ancora che in due no
nuke perfetto andiamo ancora regredire
ok vai con una mano sola perché noi
siamo dei pro se non è finita di dirlo è
andato su proprio devo andare su winners
non va bene
devo vincerlo draga impossibile vincere
sto boltro
ma che cazzo è stata ok pensavo che
dovessi sopravvivere anche perché dopo
se non vincevo dopo tutto sto casino
incazzavo ok best level never ok questo
mi ha attirato un casino il nome there's
no finger ok mi sa che non c'era niente
veramente ok invece sì ai talk io invece
sono ancora vivo top
ok ma mi sa che veramente non c'è nulla
quindi devo restare perfetto ok da hera
che andiamo dalla parte giusta
justin bieber cos'è sta roba cup si devo
passare da una piattaforma all'altra
minchia un casino ok da uk awesome epic
già stiamo facendo incredibile dai look
vai tu lo faccio è fatta perché sta
vagando come non so cosa va beh son
caduto sono arrivato a epic e mi basta
senza far caso a come sono rimaste le
gambe del padre andiamo a cambiar
livello long spike follo non so neanche
cosa vuol dire spike però vabbè
proviamoci ha preso steve spagna
sarebbero si cosi merda merda merda
ok ok ok ho capito come si fa almeno si
stima è giusto da utilizzare perché
forse quello che riesce a farlo meglio
vai perché ci hai un pene al posto del
fuoco no ok riproviamoci chip ciao raga
ho fatto il salto più epico di sempre
[Musica]
vabbè riproviamoci è stata una cosa
assurda non so neanche come ho fatto
sembrava che lo facesse in slow motion
ok staccati staccati merda finché non ci
riescono no staccati steve stack bravo
steve grandissimo così steve adesso sei
sopravvissuto due volte però la terza mi
sa di no almeno la lascio niente neanche
lasciarlo finita di cadere e è
impossibile questo ci devo ok epic
banhart che minchia è aspettate un
attimo che lo devo provare solo perché
per curiosità più che altro ok o hard
saving greenbox ok e bebè tipo ideate mi
piace né uno non sarà così di finire
ok va bene a noi due stronzo
ok se lo vedi quel lo vedi questo adesso
il mio obiettivo non è il traguardo sei
tu brutto stronzo perché non mi hai
preso
ho vinto piuttosto no ok mi chiamerò
male sta cadendo pure di sotto vabbè
comunque raga come al solito mi avete
inviato un livello fatto da voi da uno
di voi che adesso andrò a giocare devo
soltanto prendere link che l'ho salvato
sul desktop ok ho trovato meno male che
li tengo sparsi i documenti di testo sul
desktop perfetto ok adesso a caso mi
trovo a volte mi trovo anche la lista
della spesa tipo non lo so vabbè
comunque lo sta caricando dovrebbe
esserci
ma che cazzo oddio ok io mi ero salvato
il livello ma non avevo ancora aperto
non toccare con la merda gatti se non
vengono dalla puzza perfetto allora tu
che hai fatto questo livello mi spieghi
che cazzo ti è venuto in mente però
vabbè non importa però vabbè facciamo lo
stesso bene sempre bello che ti sei dato
da fare
direi di partire vai vai con gli occhi
lo zio che cosa schifosa perfetto sono
sono salvo quindi perché ci aveva una
balena attaccata al culo perfetto vai
avanti
ok è babbo natale non ci tengo ad
attaccarmi a lui perfetto neanche i
folletti se per questo già sto per fare
ce la sto per fare non ci credo no
maledetti bambini toglietevi dalle palle
perfetto se grandissimo grandissimo
steve dovrei aver vinto perfetto e c'è
anche vai al cesso
vai accesso tutto contento a livello per
farvi j grazie mille
molto gentile bello tutto quanto ti
consiglio soltanto di farti un esame di
coscienza perché un livello così non
l'avevo mai visto però lasciamo perdere
ok va beh direi che posso chiudere qui
raga perché anche mia partita si è più
visto iniziare come al solito se vi è
piaciuto il video lasciate come al
solito se vi è piaciuto il video
lasciate un commento mi piace anche alla
pagina di facebook che come al solito
trovate nella descrizione di ogni mio
video
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
e noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
bella ragazzi